ils finirent le pot est prêt les
troqueurs
brigade
hausse avec le référendum ce très serré
donc on note effectivement un clan b on
a aussi un gouverneur du massachusetts
charlie véhicule qui est bien décidé à
ce que l'entente soit mise en place
déception du côté d'hydro-québec ce
matin déception du côté du premier
ministre vous venez de l'entente
pourquoi parce que les résidents du
maine lors d'un référendum tenu hier ont
dit non à cette construction d'une ligne
électrique pour descendre d'électricité
du québec vers le massachusetts et un
contrat de 10 milliards de dollars pour
les dix prochaines années ou 11
milliards se fit brochu grande patronne
d'hydro-québec est avec nous en direct
alain brochu bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
roy alors est ce que ça veut dire que
vous allez être obligé de passer par un
autre chemin
non en fait l'eau ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est qu'il ya une partie de
la population qui a utilisé son appel
d'une initiative populaire pour mettre
dans un référendum un projet de loi
alors quand on dit demain on va tourner
dos au projet faut faire attention parce
que ce projet là il est en construction
il a été autorisé par toutes les
institutions du maine par les
institutions fédérales par tous les
organismes qui devait voir à la
l'acceptabilité et aux bénéfices
environnementaux économiques du projet
donc ce projet là il a franchi toutes
les îles à tous les permis c ou quoi
depuis plusieurs mois il y un
construction par les producteurs
d'électricité à partir d'énergies facile
en trouver une autre idée parce qu'il
nous envoie comme ça
la quinzaine une idée de susciter à
travers une initiative populaire
référendum pour que les gens s'expriment
dans un parfait mais non on n'en veut
pas alors ils ont ils ont utilisé cette
cette démarche qui existent en mon
pouvoir pour plus convaincus et 60 mille
signatures on peut déposer un projet de
loi citoyens et les entreprises fassent
ils ont payé déjà qu'il sera laporte
recueillir des signatures ils ont tenu
une campagne je le dis depuis plusieurs
mois de désinformation qu'ils ont faite
ma foi ses stars mais dans tous les cas
de figure ils ont prévalu hier il ya des
gens au maine il ya trois cent mille
personnes je pense qu'ils se sont et ont
voté ou quatre cent mille personnes là
dessus 60 % ont dit qu'ils ont et qu'ils
approuvaient le projet de loi en
question le projet de loi la démarche
est correct le projet de loi en question
lui il est illégal parce qu'il dit il il
veut donner aux municipalités un pouvoir
rétroactif sur un projet que tous ses
permis est en construction lorsqu'elle
va te faire [ __ ] le futur séparé mais
nous ce qu'on prétend c'est que c'est
illégal alors on n'est pas du tout en
train de trouver les chemins se voit on
va aller en haut on va être très
respectueux faire valoir les droits et
les droits et qu'il est à deux doigts
valoir vous êtes on va aller en cours
puis vous êtes très confiant de
remporter parce que il faut bien
comprendre vous l'avez dit mais je veux
souligner pour les gens qui nous
écoutent ce projet-là été approuvé comme
dit par les autorités par le président
parce que la présidence doit donner son
avis parce qu'on importe de l'ailé de
l'énergie de notre pays vous avez tous
les feux verts donc vous avez mis
combien d'argent là dedans tu déjà
engagé à la construction
mais en fait construction en fait depuis
les tout débuts du projet clov faut tout
mettre là-dedans pour être les plans des
processus réglementaire autorisation et
où on doit un peu au nord de 500
millions bleus mais c'est normal on
aurait projets ont permis en avance
alors je comprendrais que on va aller on
va les défendre les droits mon
partenaire et va le faire aussi défendre
les droits d'hydro-québec et un contre
et obtenu est il des permis ont été
obtenus dans une fois c'est ce soit fois
mais la citroën czéro ville vous êtes on
va se battre encore est ce que un c'est
à dire que les travaux seront
interrompus ou vous pouvez même continué
comme si de rien n'était ouais bah en
fait d'abord y reviendra comme si de
rien n'était parce qu'évidemment près de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui les gens
travaillaient on avait 5 six cents
ouvriers sur le chantier
ce que notre partenaire américain en
fait il ya un faisceau sur la fin de
l'après midi il déposé sa demande pour
que le projet de loi qui était évoqué
votre poids en force alors je vous
explique dans un projet de loi est
soignée comme ça lorsqu'il est lorsqu'il
est majoritaire le ou la gouverneure 30
jours je pense pour dire le projet de
loi de tombes en force et donc il faut
nous il faut que ce projet-là de ton pas
en force pour ne pas qu'ils tombent en
force il faut qu'on sorte ject au fait
qu'il le reçoive le sceau de la
gouverneure gouverneur qui appuient
encore le projet qui est très derrière
le projet fait tout ça est un peu
curieux mais en et antennes américaines
et on fait comme des américains oui il
faut le souligner le gouverneur est
d'accord en fait eu beaucoup de gens
d'accord mais ce sont des citoyens parce
que les oppose à vos concurrents
américains qui produisent l'électricité
du charbon en trop sont contre
évidemment que vous envahissent y est
entre guillemets le marché est ce que ça
peut néanmoins sophie brochu retarder
tout ça c'est à blériot pour 2 22 euros
et c'est sur c'est certain et compte à
moins d'un moins d'un miracle je
n'espère pas parce que la taxe émane de
ces gens là c'est de tout faire pour
retarder puis à marie de décourager les
gens avec moi que cela de mona pour nous
décourager le parce que on est très
déterminé à aller au bout de ça il va y
avoir des délais nécessairement je suis
pas capable de vous dire exactement
combien de femmes à quelques bonjour ou
ont recommencé à s'envoyer des
injonctions il est fort à parier que ont
pu savoir un délai important la jolie t
je sais pas exactement des premiers mois
mais ça s'peut donc c'est un an c'est
vraiment un an et met sa pauvre en
plaine comme 26 mai ce roi combien on
peut dire de belles paroles et et
s'enflammer et le dire ça nous prend des
énergies renouvelables sur le terrain
des entreprises qui ont beaucoup
d'argent les entreprises d'ailleurs qui
se targue d'être aussi des productrices
d'énergies renouvelables extérieur
pendant nos villes qui avaient le plus
d'argent dans tout cela une entreprise
qui produit du christ à partir de gaz de
seconde et d'autres combustibles
fossiles m'a fait aussi l'énergie
renouvelable mais dans son modèle
d'affaires est beaucoup plus lourde en
production facile qu'à redoubler
d'ailleurs le fbi la nouvelle bourse
vient de les éjecter les entreprises de
là ils sont ils travaillent jamais
vision me lever 1 ils vont financer des
groupes locaux qui serre la main du
diable puis ils vont faire
la ville ok je reviens quand même sur
les délais on parle de plusieurs
admettent en 2022 on parle de plusieurs
années avant d'envoyer devant notre
électricité au massachusetts mais
écoutez on devait le projet devait payer
son électricité en 20 22 sur la fin 2 2
présentement là je n'ai pas de
visibilité zinc parce qu'on doit
regarder l'ensemble des procédures de
care qui est en vente dans un univers
qu'il dépense mon champ de compétence
que 2 s'est jamais arrivé c'est ce qui
c'est arrivé tellement c'est byzantin
comme vous êtes avoir fait ça va se
faire regardez le moal et nous nous nous
qu'on dit la secte et c'est pas comme si
on allait deux permis sur trois ont eu
tous les permis de commencer à
construire les gens sont là il ya des
droits acquis on de commencer à
travailler sur le droit de passage en
225 milles de fait alors on peut pas ce
que je disais on peut pas dire est
qu'elle prenne parti de rock et le
siffleur celui d'un gouffre que dans la
nuit un groupe que perdu et puis quand
on se rendit dans le monde et leur
disent maintenant les deux prolongations
ça marche pas comme ça voilà je content
pour new york fait rien à voir est ce
que ça on peut entrevoir le même genre
de d'embûches absolument les entreprises
fois celle là et je les range bas de
gamme
et louis b et en me disant le modèle
d'affaires
l'iceberg dérive vers les mers du sud
il bat est méritée et aujourd'hui ils
ont un marché qui katif qu'ils peuvent
revendre l'électricité
en fait dans nos coutumes belge que ça
leur coûtait en morceaux sur le marché
puis les marches est obligé d'acheter de
l'électricité parce qu'ils ont peu
d'options alors aujourd'hui on arrive on
est concurrentiel renouvelables nous
coûte moins cher que jaune alors
beaucoup au 1e on est on est le nid à va
mais nous on prend personne comme ennemi
nous on avance dans la volonté
planétaire de décarbonés avec une
approche rigoureuse vous embrasse tous
les permis requis
mais c'est pas vrai on va se donner des
jambes est légale par des entreprises
qui n'ont pas que ne partage pas cette
vision là si on a des pommes sont en
avait mal fait procéder sénat répond
tous les permis et qu'on était ajoute qu
on était tout croche que des gens ces
documents design et puis l'accord
comprendrait voilà on est pros du web
ont dû construire derrière la cause des
femmes
du québec et les intérêts de tout cela
ne reste à quelqu'un qui veut que ce
projet lui arrive non non je reste mais
avant de vous laisser aller j'ai rien à
voir mais je veux vous poser la question
ça brûle les lèvres maintenant le
ruisseau télé grand patron vous
connaissez tous
michael russo grand grand grand patron
d'air canada qui vient la chambre de
commerce à montréal qu'il savait vous je
n'ai pas l'intention d'apprendre le
français ça m'intéresse pas il ya
d'autres choses qui m'intéressent ça
vous choque ou comme chef d'entreprise
mais je vous dit deux affaires d'abord
sur le coup je me suis dit mais au moins
il dit parce que bien des gens qu'ils
voient en défense et d'attaqué
fait déjà les ans après son opus poser
des questions noté sur une entreprise
comme ça qui sont très nécessaire
qu'elle viendra venez scoop parlait très
bien les deux langues enfin qu'il
parlait bien les deux ans pour
parfaitement et de long qui parlait bien
les deux hommes puis ont des mets que le
président vert canada sont capables de
s'exprimer dans les deux langues
officielles dirigeants une organisation
qui qui est justement travail dans les
deux langues officielles moi je peux
juste encourager le juste encourager
n'importe quel dirigeant qui arrive dans
un autre pays de pouvoir s'exprimer un
minimum dans le coeur à la langue du
coeur des et peut-être que le fait que
air canada manque une opportunité est ce
que ça cache et l'accompagnateur non ça
va décevoir avec sûrement
sophie brochu merci beaucoup de nous
avoir parlé toujours aussi clair merci
on va suivre tout ça merci beaucoup
merci
car ici on est toujours sûr
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici r d